we never thought we'd say this but we
miss you Maleficent we haven't seen your
wicked face or heard your maniacal laugh
since the very first descendants film we
know mal had her reasons for turning you
into a lizard but why didn't she turn
you back once she freed everyone from
the Isle of the laws that just doesn't
seem fair if we were you we'd be
planning our revenge it's just too bad
that you're still a lizard we really
missed you in descendants three and
everyone in Oregon lived happily ever
after
except for Maleficent what happened to
the strongest Disney villain of all time
what rock is she hiding under and is she
still a wizard keep watching to find out
your mother did she shrank to the size
of the love in her heart
growing up with Maleficent as a mom was
super tough but it did turn mal into the
fighter she is today
sure Maleficent wanted to bring down the
barrier and punish everyone who'd
wronged her but she did have her reasons
Philippa didn't put all her eggs into
one basket when she sent mal de Oregon
with a special task but she never
expected her daughter to have a change
of heart well if isn't tried to take on
mal and her friends at the end of the
first descendants film but Mouse magic
was infused with love whereas Maleficent
stemmed from anger so when their spells
clashed Maleficent was transformed into
a puny lizard lipid since miserable
existence is living proof that sometimes
you get exactly what you asked for I
will be able to bend all Maleficent one
it was for Mau to bring down the barrier
using fairy godmothers wand and that's
exactly what happened the next time you
ask for something be sure to be specific
fairy godmother willingly gave mal her
wand at the end of descendants three and
now took down the barrier for good and
while mal got to welcome her dad auradon
with open arms
this same can't be said about her mother
so why would mal side with Hades instead
of her dear old mom Eadie's made it
crystal clear that Maleficent isn't
easiest person to get along with but
when Hades accused mal of hating her
mother she quickly fired back we know
that mal kept Maleficent as a pet
throughout descendants - but we haven't
seen the little evil lizard since then
if turning Maleficent into a lizard and
keeping her that way is the symbol of
Mao's love we'd hate to see what she
does to someone she hates in descendants
- mal decides to move back to the Isle
of the Lost where she belongs
we see her put Maleficent into a tiny
little box and bring her back to the
Isle but since magic doesn't work on the
Isle shouldn't Maleficent have turned
back into her usual self like melded in
descendants 3 well apparently not
Maleficent might be evil but living the
rest of her days as a lizard is
something we wouldn't wish on our worst
enemy now should have turned her mother
back and locked her back up on the Isle
with the rest of the villains but this
never happened
so why didn't mal turn her mom back into
her usual self
well for one mal is probably terrified
of what her mother will say once she
finds her voice again who wouldn't be
furious with their child for keeping
them as a pet Maleficent wouldn't
hesitate to get revenge on mal and since
mal probably feels guilty she might not
be able to beat her mother once again
but the most obvious reason why
Maleficent is still a lizard has
everything to do with how evil she is
taking down the barrier and freeing
everyone from the Isle just wouldn't
have been possible if Maleficent was
still calling the shots she's more
interested in revenge than making amends
if Maleficent was still ruling the Isles
the people of auradon would have never
agreed to take down the barrier because
that would give Maleficent all of her
powers back and she just loves throwing
evil spells around whether mal would
free her mother or not is sort of
irrelevant after all we haven't seen the
tiny lizard since mal brought it to the
Isle indeed - so what if Mel actually
lost her mom on the Isle making it
impossible to undo this spell now had to
leave in a hurry once king Ben was
kidnapped by uma and her pirates so it's
possible that she left her belongings
behind
and couldn't retrieve her dear old mum
we just hope that Maleficent made it out
of the box she was being held captive in
without the proper food and nourishment
that little lizard wouldn't be able to
survive
Maleficent might be evil and super
powerful but she does have a heart would
Hades have married her if she didn't
Maleficent is complicated and
unpredictable but she deserves some
credit and she definitely doesn't
deserve to live the rest of her days as
a lizard
although eighty saved Audrey at the end
of descendant 3 therefore redeeming
himself in the eyes of mal Maleficent
could have done the exact same thing if
Maleficent had used her sceptre to heal
Audrey she would have patched things up
with Queen Leah Sleeping Beauty and
Audrey all at once there is nothing that
says I'm sorry
like saving the granddaughter or your
enemy unfortunately Maleficent never got
the chance to redeem herself she's
nowhere to be found
do you think Maleficent deserves to live
the rest of her life as a lizard or do
you think mal should undo the spell tell
us in the comments section thanks for
watching
subscribe to the things and hit that
notification bell so you never miss
another video and don't forget to give
this one a big thumbs up we'll catch you
next time
[Music]